if you go back in time and give one
piece of advice to yourself what it
would it be this is real as [ __ ]
something andrew schultz said to me
years ago he said the moment you are
immune to rejection you are unstoppable
go ask every girl out that you think is
cute and if she says no who gives a [ __ ]
it's actually hilarious that a girl says
you're not good enough to date me it's
so funny
it's great good for you now you know
move on ask another girl she says no who
cares you're fine get rejected fail all
the time and learn from it and the
better you handle the rejection i
remember i was uh before i met my wife i
wasn't even trying to like i was just
trying to like get better at talking to
girls i would get rejected by girls and
be so like unfazed by it and think it
was so funny that sometimes it flipped
him
yeah it happened a couple times it was
like i would just be like i get it you
know what i mean or whatever i would
just be as funny as i could with it and
then weirdly it flipped them a couple
times